[Music]
let's go to bill in atlanta georgia hey
bill what's up brother
hey dr dudes and honored to be speaking
with you it's an honor to talk to you my
man how can i help today
so
i guess the question i have today is
you know i'm feeling dissatisfied in my
marriage i want to see if it's worth
continuing or not okay tell me about it
so my wife and i started dating when we
were both 15 years old
um you know so we've been together for
10 years now two of those we were
married and we still very much love each
other we're best friends and we don't
have any kids together so
life is is going pretty good for the
most part but just recently i've been
feeling a lot more dissatisfied with
um
you know me never having dated anyone
else or truly lived the single life um
the single life baby oh you missed it
bill you missed the single life
i did i did so what what is um tell me
what this
what do you think you missed
or even better even better because it's
not over yet what are you missing right
now
not having made a connection with anyone
except for this one person
so what what does that mean you wish you
had sex with more people no
not that you wish you'd like gotten to
laugh and hang out and go see how
somebody else danced i mean what what is
the thing help me articulate it
just what you said now it's
seeing other personalities and seeing
what works for me um enjoying
doing new things with someone
and and seeing if they're the right fit
for me and
going through a trial period you know
where you you date and you see they're
good and
things like that it's not so much really
a sexual thing at all it's just more of
did i find the right person for me
um and so you've got somebody that
you've been with for 10 years now
married two of those years
and y'all are best friends
and things are going great
and
but there's that nagging feeling that
it could all be better than this
correct
and so when somebody
hey let me tell you this you're not
crazy
okay
what you're feeling is totally totally
normal
you're not nuts you've been married what
two years now
correct okay yeah you're not crazy
you're 25
correct okay
i don't know
many if anyone
who hasn't wondered
did i do the right thing
especially somebody who's dated somebody
since high school
what would have been like to kiss
somebody else what would it be like to
get to know somebody else's family
and the goal you just described you just
laid out a perfect path of what that
would be like like that anticipation and
that
your heart's beating and you're
putting on cologne for the first time
all the things right you clean your car
out before all that nervous energy that
you get before a date some people hate
that and they love getting married
because that's finally over some people
miss that
i personally miss that okay i loved the
apprehension
of is this going to go well is it not
going to go well do i hold somebody's
hand and screw up and waste the whole
movie trying to hold somebody's hand do
i guess and see what kind of gift is
gonna be good and ah that wasn't good i
miss all that my wife
hated that okay so some people are one
with somebody other
but now you find yourself wondering what
would it all be like and i want to do it
all over again so that you can just land
right where you are
with somebody who's your best friend 10
years later
someone that you're sexually compatible
with that you love that things are good
does that make sense
yeah so when you're telling me it's not
the relationship
it is
sounds like you're bored
i am and there is some parts to the
relationship too
um there we go what are they
so we're not
the perfect couple of course everyone
has their issues wow but these are big
what are they be honest
and you probably haven't told people
this what are they i i i admit i am
ashamed of making this call i don't like
admitting any of this i don't have
anyone to talk to and here's what i'm
telling you you're helping a bunch of
folks because there's a bunch of people
who are in your same boat okay
absolutely you're being brave but you're
not telling me the full truth
okay so our arguments lately
they've been getting worse more
energetic but energetic that's a
very kind way of saying
violent um
there is i i don't hit her but she
does know that she hasn't named a
problem and
you know so being hit isn't
me being hit isn't too much of a
surprise
um so things like that that's a very
critical question your wife is
physically abusing you
not that way it's like is your wife is
your wife hitting you
correct that is physical abuse my
brother
that's not a knock on your masculinity
and i'm tough i can handle it that's
physical abuse
okay
call it what it is
all right okay um
and so your fights are getting explosive
fight explosive fights are almost always
a symptom not the problem
what is the gap in your marriage
um
there is
there's forms of resentment of course
there are
me being
dissatisfied like i said earlier and
then
since we've been married um well while i
was in college and we were dating she
was holding her own well and she was
paying all her bills and working jobs
just to make sure that she's still
sustaining and ever since we got married
it's things like
her not having a sustainable job
her not i guess
she's trying to look for jobs but she's
not putting her foot forward to
to look for that
as much as i would like and so
while we're paying off that i like the
extra income and since it's not
happening i'm feeling resentment towards
that and she's aware
um also i'm realizing that our
personalities
don't match anymore since we got married
um while we were in dating and i was in
college and high school life was great
because we got along i mean we
practically grew up with each other um
dating and so since we got married
everything
kind of shifted in the opposite
direction us our personalities did so i
became more of a tightwad with money and
she's more of she's a very very loose
person when it comes to money she's a
free spirit and in a way that seems to
me as debilitating as long as one comes
in the money comes out life is good
you know i'm trying to live by favoring
standards
so it bothers me in that direction
and then our personalities with regards
to
our sense of humor and our conversations
that we have and
things like her spending a lot of time
on the phone and he's spending a lot of
time on the phone it's just been
it's been
feeling like we're more friends than we
are a married couple um and now that
we're adults now we pay bills and we
bought a house and
we have dogs which it kind of counts as
kids although a lot of people give me
hate for that
okay can i ask you something
what's up you've got your eye on
somebody else who is it
so that was where i was going next i
know it is who is it
it's it's a friend of a friend another
and
we kind of realized that our
personalities meshed perfectly she
actually grew up
20 minutes
away from me hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on just stop
because you created a fantasy now
i did and you're gonna make all of those
puzzle pieces of that fantasy
match
and i'm telling you right now it's not
real
now i'm not saying that your marriage
isn't in trouble it is
but this will not be the solution to
your marriage
okay
i'm telling you
you gotta trust me on this
okay
and it feels so right because everything
in your world feels like it's so wrong
and she is giving you the butterflies
she's giving you the
oh yeah everything just meshes right now
and works i'm telling you it doesn't
it's a fantasy it's not real
now you could throw your marriage away
and go date this woman
and decide i'm gonna make this one work
that could happen
but the odds of the exact same thing
happening six months eight months ten
months down the road are astronomical
they're gonna happen
so here's what's happened in your
marriage y'all got married and you quit
you quit wooing each other
you quit leaning into each other you
quit saying hey how can i make his life
better how can i make her life better
and when you got married you started
saying now how this is how this is gonna
be
and she said nope this is how this is
gonna be
and then slowly you guys started
watering the seeds of resentment
and it wouldn't surprise me if she's got
her eyes on somebody else or that she's
just completely parked it
right and then it starts with
sex is a little bit awkward
it's not cool or invigorating or
exciting because we've chosen for it to
not be
and then we quit trying on dates
and then we just quit going on dates
when we just watch a movie we're here oh
and then there's covet we're stuck here
right and then you say things like our
personalities don't match anymore i call
bull crap on that
you all are choosing to not be friends
me and my wife my wife thinks that will
ferrell is the least funny person who's
ever lived other than chris farley
and i think the reverse of that i think
she has a mental disorder because she
believes that i think chris farley is
one of the funniest people who's ever
walked the earth followed only by will
ferrell
and phil hartman right so
the fact that we think different things
are funny doesn't mean our personalities
don't match and we should end a 10-year
friendship
it means i'm choosing
to be oppositional to her
right
we've stopped wooing
and what i'm telling you right now is
you're leaning into a fantasy brother
and she is too whether she's got
somebody else that she's got her eye on
or
the fantasy that she's living in which
is i can just do whatever i want with no
consequences i can spend money like
crazy i don't have to work i don't have
to do that that's a fantasy too
but what it doesn't sound like anybody
in your home has done is flip the lights
on and said we've got 10 years
of being best friends of growing up
together
nobody knows us like we each other does
and honey i'm starting to imagine my
life not with you
and i don't want to do that terrified to
lose you
but this is where my head's at that's
where my heart's at
and i feel it's growing way way apart
and vice versa have you done that have
you thrown the lights on turned the
music off and said what are we doing
no why why she's worth that you're worth
it why
i wanted to avoid the conversation i
have a feeling i know where this is
gonna go it's just gonna lead to another
big fight and i didn't wanna go through
it so tell her i'm not fighting you
and if you are physically ass if you
physically assault me again i'm going to
call cops
it sounds like she's trying to
manufacture emotion in that relationship
i'm not saying it's right it's wrong
but trying to just throw molotov
cocktails of passion up against the wall
to see if something sticks
does that make sense
yeah
and brother you are cashing out on a
fantasy it's not
real
you know where i was cashing out was um
with with all the issues i laid out in
the beginning
and then talking to this other person it
made me realize you know what would it
be like
and you said this what would it be like
if i had
dated been with someone else someone i
feel more compatible with
um
you're saying it's not real i i agree
with you and i believe you but
how how do i know without without the
proof in the pudding you know what i
mean
how do you know
have you ever taken gasoline and
fertilizer
and blown up a bomb in your living room
just to see what would happen
no no no have you gone to see pictures
of
the federal building in oklahoma
no
google it
and you'll see one of the most
incredible acts of domestic terrorism
ever
when timothy mcveigh blew up the federal
building and killed a bunch of children
and workers
go visit that monument
you can know something isn't right
without experiencing it firsthand in
fact it would be stupid to experience
that firsthand
so if you want to detonate a bomb in
your living room go right ahead i'm
telling you what the end result is going
to be
so how do i know
you're asking the wrong question
the question is not how do i know if i'm
not missing out on something of course
you're missing out on something here's
the thing you would go out with this
woman and y'all have some great laughs
and y'all would hold hands and you'd get
all
and you'd feel all
your heart would beat and flutter and it
would be all new and blah blah blah and
it'd be all that stuff it would be
awesome it would
and then it would be the same stuff
because you're not dealing with you
and you're not dealing this is how you
deal with friendships that start to get
messy you run
and so
what
the worst part about this new
relationship is that
bill would go with bill
and bill's the guy that just cashes out
10-year relationships
yeah we just grew apart
how do i know i understand i don't know
you're asking the wrong question the
wrong question is
how do i save
my best friend
how do i save my relationship with my
best friend
how do i stop avoiding hard
conversations
how do i have hard conversations that
don't end in physical violence
you look her in the eye and say i'm not
giving up on this and this is not okay
and so i booked us an appointment a half
day with a marriage therapist here in
atlanta
and
i'm all in on this
because this is half of our life
that's how you know
if you go chasing good feelings brother
you're gonna end up miserable and alone
because there's always hard stuff to
work through in a marriage always always
always always and what i'm gonna tell
you dude
is
you are worth not cashing this
relationship out
and she's not i'm not telling you that
the marriage is gonna be saved i'm not
what i'm telling you is you're looking
for the coward's way out you're looking
for a soft place to land because it's
getting uncomfortable
and you're you know what you're more
than uncomfortable you're an abusive
relationship you are okay
you're an abusive relationship and to
everyone that i am if the if the tables
were reversed
i'd be telling her to run okay so i'm
telling you you gotta flip flip the
lights on she can't be hitting you when
y'all get in fights it's not cool no
violence in the house
but running into the arms of somebody
else as though that's gonna solve this
deal is not
accurate it's not true it's not right
so get a marriage therapist
get somebody you trust whether it's her
friend her sister
your friend your sister somebody that
both of you all trust
and you go and say i'm losing this
marriage and now all of a sudden i'm
starting thinking about plans with
somebody else and i'm not going there
but i'm not losing you either
all the lights come
on and you can tell her if you hit me
again i'm calling the police
you're not gonna be violent in this
house
and if you're yelling and screaming
bill stop it
be a grown-up
be mature
but don't give up this relationship this
friendship this marriage is love without
a fight
don't
don't
especially for someone who's more our
personalities fit a little bit better
don't
don't
you're worth more than this and so is
she
call somebody today bill